mathis sentence à 21 ans est un habitué
des courses de chiens de traîneaux avec
ses 5 husky atteler à son kart il a
parcouru le tracé de 7 km 500 à travers
la forêt sainte apolline de plaisir et
pour aller plus vite il a sa stratégie
je mets un mâle et une femelle devant
pour pour avoir un peu de d'obéissance
et de et disons de vitesse parce que
c'est avec les femelles sont plus
obéissante très mal et je mets de mal à
l'arrière pour pour donner donner une
bonne puissance à côté des cartes tracts
et au maximum par huit chiens il ya les
trottinettes et des vélos frédéric et
marjorie ont commencé il y a deux ans
chacun son chien les duos frédéric reiko
en trottinette et marjorie pria à vélo
moi j'aime beaucoup les départs avec
avec pria parce qu'elle est vraiment
dans l'excitation et donc du coup c'est
la voir comme ça on voit qu'ils prennent
plaisir à ça en fait donc c'est ce et
puis ça permet de créer un lien avec son
chien qu'on a peut-être moins quand on
fait moins d'activité la course dans la
forêt à plaisir un rendez vous
incontournable organisé par le club de
poule k et du traîneau à chiens
d'ile-de-france depuis 36 ans il a
rassemblé pour l'édition 2000 21 70
pilotes et entre 300 et 400 chiens qui
viennent de toute la france c'est aussi
une compétition à chaque manche les
attelages marque des points suivant leur
classement et donc 1
un classement en fin d'année en fin de
saison trois courses sur terre sont au
programme d'ici à la mi-décembre
viennent ensuite plusieurs étapes sur
neige jusqu'à la fin du mois de mars
puis les courses sur terre reprenne
avant la fin de la saison prévu en avril